people who have lung conditions like
asthma or copd often take their
medications using a handheld device
called a metered dose inhaler or mdi
with a spacer
a metered dose inhaler sprays medicine
through your mouth so that it can reach
your airways
if your inhaler is not used the right
way some medicine may remain in the back
of your mouth and not reach your airways
where it is needed
this video will show you the general
steps for correctly using an inhaler
with a spacer
it's important to follow the
instructions that came with your metered
dose inhaler and spacer
a metered dose inhaler has three main
parts the mouthpiece cover
the mouthpiece
and the medicine container
a spacer helps get more medicine into
your airways the spacer attaches to your
inhaler's mouthpiece
it also has a mouthpiece and cap
before using your metered dose inhaler
remove the mouthpiece cap and shake the
inhaler
next remove the cap from the spacer and
make sure it's clean inside
if this is the first time you are using
your inhaler or if you haven't used it
in a while you will need to prime it
before placing it in the spacer
check the instructions for how and when
to do this with your inhaler
attach your spacer to your inhaler
when you're ready to use your inhaler
stand or sit up straight
breathe in deeply and breathe out
completely to empty your lungs
put the spacer's mouthpiece in your
mouth between your teeth and above your
tongue
then close your lips around the
mouthpiece to form a tight seal
press down firmly on the top of your
inhaler to release one puff of medicine
into the spacer
and breathe in as slowly and as deeply
as you can
if you hear a whistling sound you are
breathing in too quickly
it is recommended that you hold your
breath for approximately a count of ten
finally breathe out slowly through your
mouth
if your medicine dose requires two puffs
you may need to wait before taking the
second puff
follow the instructions that came with
your inhaler to know how long to wait
between puffs
after using a steroid inhaler rinse out
your mouth with water and spit it out
it's important to clean your inhaler and
spacer so that they work properly
check the instructions for your inhaler
and spacer for the right way to clean
them
proper use of your metered dose inhaler
may help you control the symptoms of
your lung condition and improve your
daily living so if you have questions
about the use of your inhaler talk to
your health care provider or pharmacist
this animation is brought to you by the
nucleus medical art library or enmol
where you can download this animation
and thousands of medical images and
videos created by nucleus medical media
to apply for a free 30-day trial click
on the link in the description
you